يعطينا بنسخه رابعه تحاكينا كبشر وتقدم
خدمات علميه وابداعيه فكثير من الناس
بداوا باستخدام الموقع ولو من باب التجربه
لكن يبدو اننا اقرب بكثير مما نتصور العيش
في عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي
سيطلق نموذجه الجديد تشارجي بيتي فور
والذي يحاكي البشر وسيشعل المنافسه بشكل
اكبر حول هذه التقنيات في الجهه الاخرى
المنافس جوجل الذي لا غنى عن استخدامه
اليوم عرض بدوره ادوات جديده للذكاء
الاصطناعي وستكون بمثابه العصا السحريه
تلك العصا ستكتب لكم رسائلكم وترسلوا
بريدكم الالكتروني وصولا الى ابتكار حملات
اعلانيه لمنتجاتكم على العموم المزيد حول
مع زميل على سرحان
بشكل عام تمثل نسخه تشات جي بي تي 4 تحسنا
كبيرا عن سابقاتها حيث تم تدريبه على
مجموعه بيانات اكبر بكثير واكثر تنوعا
واصبح نموذجا محدثا بالمعلومات واجاباته
اكثر دقه كما يتمتع بقدرات لغويه اقوى هذا
جعله اداه اكثر قوه لانشاء المحادثات بل
ايضا يتعامل مع لغات اكثر في العدد يمكن
قراءه الصور وفهمها بينما النسخ السابقه
اقتصرت على النصوص ايضا يصعب خداعه وتجنب
المطالبات الخبيثه وهو ما طالب مستخدمون
من شركه اوبن اي بتدريب النسخ الجديده على
تطويرها بعيدا عن الشر يحتوي ايجيبتيفور
على ذاكره اطول سيتذكر ما تحدثتما عنه في
20 صفحه سابقه من الدردشه من الدردشه وقد
يشير الى محادثات تمت قبل 35
بناء صفحه اخيرا يتمتع ببنيه شبكه عصبيه
اكثر قوه تمكنه من معالجه المعلومات
باستجابات اسرع بل شبيهه بالبشر في
مطالبات معينه
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم لنا الخبير في امن المعلومات
رئيس سمور سيد رائد اهلا بكم من جديد معنا
في صباح العربيه يسعد صباحك نستضيفك كمان
حتى نحكي عن العالم واستقطب الاهتمام
اليوم نتحدث عن نسخه جديده
يقال انها اقوى من السابق بمئه ترليون من
البيانات وتعد اكثر قدره وتفوقا على انتاج
الافلام وانتاج النصوص بالفعل تعتبر كذلك
يعني ما الذي يميزها تحديدا النسخه
الرابعه
صباح الخير اهلا بك في الحقيقه هو النسخه
الرابعه غيرت قواعد اللعبه في موضوع
التشاجي
بحيث انه اصبحت المدخلات والمخرجات فيها
متعدده الوظائف بمعنى انه بالبدايه كان
ياخذ نص ويتعامل مع نص الان بده ياخذ صوره
ويتعامل مع صوره ويخرج في المخرجات صوره
وفي مرحله قادمه سوف يكون هناك في فيديو
يعني ياخذ فيديو ويكون في هناك مخرجات
ايضا على عن طريق فيديو فهنا عمليه
التعامل مع تشاء سوف تختلف فيها متعه
زياده فيها اثاره زياده فيها عمق زياده
فيها اكثر موضوعيه واكثر دقه نعم لانه
النسخ السابقه كانت تعتمد على قواعد
البيانات ما قبل 2021 واعتقد ان النسخه
الرابعه سوف تعتمد على بيانات 22 23
فعمليا نسبه الدقه فيها حتكون اعلى بكثير
مما كانت
استاذ رائد للمفارقه انه على جوجل صدر
البحث شات جي بي تي 4 هذا بالنسبه لمحرك
البحث على جوجل بس اليوم
يعني خلق حاله جنون اليوم لدى المستخدمين
ولدا البشر هل نتحدث عن طفره وستنتهي يعني
مثل طفره طفرات اخرى سابقه اما اليوم لا
هذا هو المستقبل اصبح جزءا لا يتجزا من
حياتنا
حتما هي ليست طفره وانما هي جزء لا يتجزا
وجزء رئيسي من بعد اليوم نعم لا مش من بعد
اليوم من 6 اشهر واحنا بنعيش في في واقع
جديد من التقنيات الحقيقه والان هاي عم
بيتطور صرنا واصلين النسخه الرابعه فعمليا
لا هذا سوف يصبح جزء لا يتجزا من حياتنا
سوف يصبح يعني هو المتحكم بممارساتنا
اليوميه على الرغم من انه هو صناعه بشريه
لكن انا اعتقد انه سوف يتحكم بالسلوك
البشري في السنوات والاشهر
والعقود القادمه لانه كل شيء سوف يعتمد
عليه طيب يتطور يقال انه متفوق في النصوص
متفوق في الصور متفوق في عدد اللغات لكن
في المقابل لديه سلبيات يعني يفتقر الى
المعرفه بالاحداث الاخيره اذا سالته وكذلك
قد يخطئ في التفريق بين البيانات الصحيحه
والحقائق او بيانات غير صحيحه والخطائك
يعني ندرس سلبيات وكذلك
والله طبعا هم هم احنا ما بنشوف الا
المدينه الفاضله من هاي التقنيات لكن ما
هو مبني على شر احنا ما بنشوفه ما هو مبني
على اساس من الممكن استخدام هذه التقنيات
في بسوء للبشريه احنا مش عم نشوفه نسبه
الخطا او انه كانت معلوماته قديمه انا
اشرت الى في جواب السابق انه كان يعتمد
على قواعد بيانات ما قبل 2021
الان اصبح يعتمد على بيانات اكثر دقه اللي
هي
2022-2023 فلا عمليا هناك
مساوئ كبيره جدا مثلا في استخدام هذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي في الحروب استخدام هذا
الذكاء الصناعي في التجسد استخدام هذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي في الاعتداء على
الخصوصيه بالنسبه للمستخدمين ما في قوانين
تحد من هذه التقنيات ومن يقوم على عمل هذه
البرمجه من يقوم على يعني اذا جاء مثلا
تنظيم ارهابي هذه التقنيات في شيء ضد
البشريه كيف يكون التعامل معه
احنا بنضل خايفين من هالتقنيات
وهالتكنولوجيا علينا وعلى خصوصيتنا وامننا
كبشر ولا نخشى على وظائفنا في المستقبل
وتميزنا وكيف سنميز الشخص المنفرد
والمتميز بافكاره عن الاخر اذا صار الكل
يلجا الى
الاجابه عن الاسئله ولتحضير حتى المقالات
ورسائل الماجستير وغيره
وادواته هي تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي اعتقد
انه
سوف يواجه مثل هذه المعضله لكن انت تخرجتي
من الجامعه الان عم تبحثي وعم بتجربي
تدخلي في مفاصل هذه التقنيه اذا انت سوف
تطوري من ادواتك وبالتالي تبقي في وظيفتك
تبقي في عملك تصوري من ادوات عملك لكن من
يبقى ومن هذا ما وجدنا عليه ابائنا أعتقد
انه هذا من سوف يخرج من المعادله وهذا من
هو سوف يخاف وسوف يحسب الف حساب لمثل هذه
التقنيات هذه التقنيات صناعه بشريه لخدمه
البشريه وليست لاقصاء البشر وليست
لاستبعاد القوه البشريه الفاعله الحقيقيه
وانما هي يعني موضوع
الترهل الاداري نعم سوف سوف تقوم على
القضاء على مثل هذه الظاهره وهذه شيء
محمود
انت بتستخدمه لتشا جي بي تي في
شكرا جزيلا لانه شيء مش طبيعي تمام يعني
هاي كانت اجابه يعني فوق التوقعات مش انه
لحد الادمان يعني انه في ناس صارت وصلت
لحد الادمان
طيب نعم حمصنا نروح كمان بتعمل فينا اكيد
واحنا كمان جربنا يعني النسخ الاوليه منه
وبانتظار انه نجرب
نمبر فور هذه المره اساليني
مين عمال الخبير فيها من المعلومات راح
تسمون شكرا جزيلا لك